las fuerzas de moscú lanzaron un ataque
múltiple la noche de ayer contra toda
ucrania estábamos en la ciudad de
mikolajki este es uno de los lugares
donde cayó uno de sus misiles que habría
sido lanzado desde el mar negro sin
embargo una de las características del
ataque de ayer es que también hubo al
menos 25 misiles lanzados desde a velo
ruso un pal país con el que linda por el
norte y donde estos misiles habrían
caído en provincias del noreste de
ucrania y también en la capital que en
cuanto a mykolaiv este sería uno de los
puntos oeste fue uno de los puntos donde
cayó uno de esos misiles estamos en uno
de los pequeños puertos cerca al río que
linda la ciudad este sería un lugar
donde están embarcaciones usadas por
estudiantes de navegación marítima este
es uno de los puertos más importantes de
ucrania y también fue un puerto
extremadamente importante durante la
época de la unión soviética aquí vemos
como un misil cayó en tierra
afortunadamente no está cerca a ninguna
edificación alcanzó buscar algunos
árboles hay algunos muros que están
caídos pero las viviendas que rodean el
lugar quedaron relativamente bien otros
ataques habrían sucedido en un colegio y
también la expansión alcanzó a la
iglesia cercana de santa catalina sin
embargo este no es un ataque aislado
mykolaiv es una ciudad que está atacada
constantemente y diariamente por las
fuerzas de mockus q y estos ataques se
han intensificado en los últimos días
cuando se ha anunciado esa
contraofensiva para retomar en la
provincia de gerzón y la capital gerson
que están a no más de 45 kilómetros de
mykolaiv